another year has come and gone and with
that more Kardashian drama major major
drama it is becoming nearly impossible
to not keep up with them and 2017 was
filled with some major moments for the
famous family Caitlyn and Kris Jenner
seem to have started 2017 on good terms
that is until Caitlyn's explosive them
or everything she says is all made up
why does everything have to be that Kris
is such a [ __ ] and an ass
the Kardashians have seemingly cut ties
with Caitlyn since then
meanwhile Kendall had a battle brewing
of her own
[Music]
the model starred in the controversial
Pepsi ad which was accused of mocking
the black lives matter movement at the
time a source told ET Kendall was
devastated over the backlash I just felt
so stupid
Kendall bounced back though by May she
was looking as confident as ever at the
Met Gala meanwhile Scott Disick rotated
through several women including Bella
Thorne and Sophia Ricci and Courtney
while she moved on with her new man
yonas Benjamin then there's Rob and
Chyna their year-long on an off
relationship hit a fever pitch with wild
accusations against each other in a
heated social media war this led to
Chyna's temporary restraining order
against her former fiance she later
dropped that and worked out a custody
agreement for their daughter dream then
came more baby fever
Kim confirmed she and Kanye will welcome
their third baby via surrogate it's
definitely a different experience and
I'm blessed that I'm able to do this
news also broke in September that Kylie
is expecting her first child with
boyfriend Travis Scott and just days
later Ichi learned Khloe is also
pregnant with her first baby with
boyfriend Tristan Thompson so how will
the growing Kardashian Empire balance it
all in 2018 I've taught my kids from day
one you know family's everything so that
comes first